[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back now the annual rate of
inflation has hit a 30-year high today
rising fuel costs strains on supply
chains and of course the war in ukraine
will see prices rise almost across the
board but what else does a 7
inflation rate mean for people that's
what it's hit we've been collecting your
questions about the cost of living
crisis throughout the day and now we
hope to answer as many of them as we can
to do that i'm joined by an expert panel
catherine chapman director of the living
wage foundation paul johnson the
director of the institute for fiscal
studies and emma revel from the british
retail consortium thank you all very
much indeed for joining us brains trust
we're going to put the old grey mata to
the test tonight uh we've got questions
starting off on the energy crisis first
uh three of them the first three are
pretty much related so we're going to
deal with the first one and then i'll
put the
other two to other members of the panel
and this first question then comes from
tony who asks will gas and electricity
prices ever return to their 2021 levels
or are we stuck with ever increasing
bills paul johnson
well would you like to have a guess at
this because it is really a guess isn't
it
i think guess is the best way of putting
it i think the first thing to remember
is that nobody was predicting this
uh a year ago so goodness knows what's
going to happen in the future there's a
lot of things in that question i don't
think we're getting ever increasing
bills or ever increasing uh inflation so
even if the energy bills stay the same
at least they won't be getting worse
i think what's most likely to happen is
that they'll come off the boil as it
were go down to levels below where they
will be
this year but for at least a period be
well above where they were a year or two
ago however we're looking into the
slightly more distant um future both
it obviously becomes much more difficult
to predict
new gas and so on is likely to come on
stream but probably more importantly for
uk households the amount of energy that
we're getting from renewables is going
up and up over time and that will
make us more insulated from what's
happening in the world
gas markets but for now i'm not
expecting uh
energy prices to go back down to
pre-crisis levels for at least two or
three years okay two or three years well
uh catherine i'd like to get your views
on that but so let me put this next
question to you because it's it's almost
directly related to this this is uh uh
from another viewer saying at what point
do you see the energy cap will increase
to enough sorry decrease to
an affordable level so right the energy
cap we know it's gone up uh this month
it's going to go up presumably again in
october when do you see it decreasing in
other words when do we see these energy
costs going down
well i mean i think it's related to paul
johnson's previous um answer that this
is incredibly complex we can't predict
the future i think where we see it
really hitting hard though is as you
said what we do know is that these
energy
prices are going to continue increasing
and being extremely unaffordable for
particularly
families on low incomes for at least the
next uh two years or so
um and what you know what this really
means in reality what we're starting to
see through the work that we do um
focused on um those earning below the
real living wage or the wage that's
needed for a decent standard of living
is having to make um families having to
make real decisions about whether to put
the heating on whether to put food on
the table and that's the kind of stark
reality
that
many families on low incomes are living
with at the moment and unfortunately
that is going to get worse in the um
kind of short to medium term we just
hope
that it will come down as soon as
possible beyond that yeah it's going to
get worse before it gets better that's
certainly the consensus so far emma
revel let me ask you about energy prices
but you know let's follow through this
supply chain and let's get up to the
retail end of it this question from
wendy says when do you think fuel prices
will start to drop on the four court are
we seeing the new normal because of
course we had that five pence duty cut
in the spring statement but that's more
or less been been gobbled up by the
rising prices already
well it's difficult to say uh if and
when prices will come down obviously
prices were increasing prior to
russia's invasion of ukraine and that
and the subsequent sanctions put
additional pressure on the cost of fuel
retailers understand cost pressures
facing motorists and are doing
everything they can to offer the best
value for money when it comes to petrol
and the fall courts and as you mentioned
you know the the fuel agility cut that
rishi soon act passed um the richardson
act gave
back in march was passed on um by
retailers you know within hours of that
announcement being made it is highly
competitive so supermarkets and other
retailers would do everything they can
to ensure the price of fuel remains as
low as possible okay let's uh put our
next question then we're broadening it
out now and this is from ashley who says
will businesses and companies be
expected to give staff and employees a
rise to match the increase in inflation
now catherine would you like to you know
have a go at that one are we going to
see and it's it's cool isn't it back in
proper inflationary times when inflation
got into double digits it's a it's a
wage price spiral
i think um what we're certainly starting
to see at the living wage foundation is
we actually are seeing employers cutting
wages up um we've seen
record numbers of employers um signing
up with the living wage foundation so
we've now got over 10 000 employers and
that are committing to pay the higher
voluntary living wage rates that are
based on what it costs to live and we've
seen record numbers signing up in the
past year and even lately the past few
months so we definitely are seeing um
employers responding in that way and
pushing wages up because we are also you
know there are high vacancy rates at the
moment there are kind of business
reasons to be doing this as well and to
attract and retain and staff there is
pressure on wages from that point of
view so we are starting to see that
certainly um at the living wage
foundation employers stepping up and
increasing wages
paul johnson can you give us the
economist's view on that
we are seeing wages now lagging of
course behind inflation do you see it in
the future those wage demands then going
up to at least keep up with inflation
well i'm sure the demands will be there
i mean i think there's there's several
groups we need to think about here the
national living wage the minimum wage is
going up by 6.6 this month which looked
really quite generous when it was
announced back in the autumn but it's
turning out to be actually below
the rate of inflation
probably most other people's wages will
go up even less quickly than that so
further behind
inflation of course we don't know what's
going to happen but it would be
surprising if they went up
more quickly than that and there's a
particular issue in the public sector
the chancellor didn't offer any more
money to public services to um education
teaching hospitals nurses and so on uh
in his recent spring statement and yet
he made the um major proposals for
spending again when he thought inflation
was gonna be a lot lot lower so there
isn't the kind of money in there to
increase the wages of teachers and
nurses and so on by anything like
the rate of inflation and don't forget
these are groups who over the last
decade or more have actually seen pay
cuts
the rest of us haven't seen much tall in
the way of pay increase it's been a
terrible decade and a bit
but for teachers and others in the
public sector they've actually seen
their pay fall already and they're
looking like seeing some more big falls
um over the next year relative to prices
okay well let's talk about another
source of pressure on family budgets
this one's from kaz about mortgage rates
and again just asking
will with soaring inflation will
mortgage rates go up
emma do you have a view on that are we
seeing that happening already
uh i'm afraid that's probably a question
for another guest i'm not sure
that's back to you then paul johnson um
i mean is it likely then that all our
mortgage rates actually beginning to
move already
they're beginning to move and they will
move a bit more uh but don't forget from
absolutely rock bottom
levels i mean interest rates are still
essentially the lowest they've ever been
in the whole of history and the bank of
england was founded in the 1600s and the
interest rates are lower than they've
ever been in all of the time that it's
been
around so yes i think we'll see some
increases in
interest rates but they will still
remain very low what really matters as
well is how low how high they are
relative to inflation so their real
level the real level of interest rates
is very very negative so you've got
inflation at um seven percent and
interest rates at two percent you're
essentially not just borrowing for free
you're worrying for much better than uh
than free and i think that's one of the
things that's really drive continuing to
drive up house prices in this world of
higher inflation of very low interest
rates
you borrowing to buy a house is one of
the best hedges you've got against uh
what's going to happen uh to inflation
going forward yeah bad luck for those
that don't um this is more up your
street amara our next question from
james uh and it's about inflation and
how high could it go um i'd say says
james it feels more like 10 inflation
rather than 7
do you think hyperinflation is going to
hit the uk in the next two years i
suppose it depends on your definition of
hyper inflation but i think james
certainly means is it going to get into
double figures at least
yeah i think it's unlikely to see
hyperinflation as it's usually defined
but inflation certainly um is is going
to continue and that's because the range
of factors that are contributing to
higher prices whether that's um labor
costs energy costs or transport costs or
global commodity prices they are all
going to continue to rise um
retailers are incredibly aware
especially when it comes to food how
price sensitive consumers can be and how
much this is essential items for
everybody so retailers are doing their
best to absorb as many of those costs um
as they can and you know many retailers
are expanding their value ranges so
people can continue to access essential
food but prices unfortunately are going
to continue to go up because the ability
of retailers to absorb those costs is
limited and catherine what does that
then mean you know back to that question
about wages if it does get 10
or above we're going to see some pretty
hefty wage demands aren't we
yeah well it just puts um
pressure on already tight um uh budgets
uh particularly for those on low earners
what we do know for those on low incomes
is that they tend to spend more
um
of their disposable income on on the
essentials on food and on housing so it
will hit those who are already
struggling the hardest unfortunately
and that's sort of what we're starting
to see and what we will probably
continue to see as these inflation
levels rise so it's really kind of
squeezing and hitting those who are
already feeling the pinch
uh
next question i think last for this
section nell wants to know very
straightforward question it's back to
you paul because we've been talking
about house prices will house prices
crash i mean you see it as a hedge
against inflation is the demand always
going to be there are they going to
house prices continue to go up
i hate making it i hate making
predictions about this so i get it wrong
continually um i mean house prices have
been going up at their fastest rate for
a very long time over the last year
which don't forget
caitlyn has come as a real surprise
again to people because remember covid
um it looked like we're all going to get
poorer um after that uh lots of people
out of work lots of people furloughed
and so on but the labour market's
incredibly strong lots of people saved
quite a lot of money interest rates are
still extremely low so
in retrospect it's not surprising to me
that house prices are rising so fast and
i don't think
i don't think house prices are likely to
crash because i think we're going to
continue to be in a world in which
interest rates are relatively low and
inflation probably fairly high uh for
a while so my guess is no we're not
going to see a house price crash
we'll how do you do that definitely paul
we'll have you back when
hopefully it doesn't happen um we're
going to take a break now you're
watching uh sky news tonight and a
special question and answer session on
the cost of living crisis uh coming up
next questions about people's personal
pensions
[Music]
gina had a sort of tingling in her bones
that she was potentially having twins
she was getting a lot of early side
effects from the pregnancy
so um within the first five seconds of
the scan the lady said oh you've got
twins congratulations we're like oh gosh
that's going to be a lot of hard work
but we can cope with that
and then 10 minutes in that cliche where
you hear people say
i've looked at you like you've got three
heads well i did that on the scan i saw
three heads and asked to scan it uh is
that right or is that just someone's
bottom and she was like no into 25 years
of scanning that's the first time i've
seen triplets and then the scanner
turned into the counsellor
because it just went very silent and we
were thinking how on earth does this
work exactly yeah i just screened out
traffic so if anyone was walking past
that room they would have like double
taken definitely we're on the higher end
of it being a little bit more unique
because they also
yes they're identical they shared a
placenta too and so that also made it
very high risk of the pregnancy as well
so it was quite a roller coaster
literally from that day of finding out
until now
so yeah we haven't got off the roller
coaster
this one i've got is jensen
uh gina has got jimmy
and this little cheeky chappie pulled in
the avocado is jackson yeah he's got
that right he got it wrong yesterday may
i just um throw that one in there
dna wise they're identical but they're
pers
they're being brought up in the same
environment we're giving them the same
care same love same nurturing but their
personalities are completely different
and i know people say who are identical
twins they're different people but
when you actually see it for yourself
they are completely different it gets
really really interesting to watch
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back to our special q a
that's a question and answer session to
you and me on the cost of living crisis
uh i'm joined by an expert panel
catherine chapman director of the living
wage foundation paul johnson from the
institute for fiscal studies and emma
revel from the british retail consortium
thanks once again for being with us
let's crack on we've got a question here
from nick who wants to know how will a
high rate of inflation affect my
personal pension
nick says he's due to start accessing my
pension next year what do you think
catherine chapman um
i mean
inflation clearly is going to erode a
pension but i suppose it depends what
kind of pension it is
yeah i mean i'm certainly not a pension
expert so other people can probably
comment um much more with much more
insight than i um but yeah as you say it
depends on what kind of pension you've
got um
he's obviously nearing the end so it
will impact more in terms of eroding the
value a bit
um i'm not sure i've got a huge more
amount more insight to give into what
you know over the long term inflation
means for pensions other than a very
general point which is obviously the
kind of squeeze it's going to put on
people the cost of living crisis is
going to put on people over the next few
years uh might mean that perhaps people
we do know that there is a looming kind
of pensions problem uh looking decades
ahead amongst particularly those on low
incomes and
not you know you know adequacy of saving
levels so i suppose the current cost of
living crisis um
is gonna um be counter to encouraging
people to say which could be just
further storing up problems for the
future um but yeah other panelists might
be able to provide more insight i'm
afraid on that well we're going to be
running but as i said it depends what
kind of pension you have if you're lucky
enough to have one of the the pretty
rare nowadays index links index linked
to pensions then you're probably okay
but most people don't have those anymore
if you're on the so-called money
purchase pension you could be in some
trouble and therefore you've got to look
at the amount of money you take out of
your pension pot you might have to
reduce that let's uh move on to lee's
question he has this thought and he says
does the bank of england have another
tool to combat inflation other than
interest rates paul johnson because i
mean that's first and foremost isn't it
what an independent bank of england's
meant to do is to police inflation and
aim to get it to around two percent
through the um the the one club policy
of interest rates does it have any other
clubs to continue with my golf analogy
does it have anything else it can do to
deal with inflation
well the bank of england doesn't have a
lot i mean it has over the last many
years um boss bought huge amounts of
government debt so-called quantitative
easing so one thing it can do is to
reverse some of that sell some of that
back into the markets as a way of taking
money out of the economy now trouble is
it's never done that before so how
effective that would be in terms of
reducing inflation
is very hard to know broadly speaking in
any case it said it wants to
get interest rates up to a particular
level one or two percent before it does
that
in any case so the bank itself has very
limited
tools and has been remarkably reluctant
to use those tools over the last
several months in any serious way partly
i think because it sees the inflation
being created to a large extent at least
outside of the uk i mean we
are not responsible for um the higher
fuel prices the higher wheat prices um
uh the higher semiconductor prices and
so on that are driving inflation but at
some point i think they're going to have
to
do a bit more because
in the end the interest rates are really
the only serious tool they've got and
actually the government itself can't do
a lot
about inflation itself again it can't
really control the prices of these
things coming into the economy unless
it's going to
take a remarkable amount of control of
the economy which um you know even in
the 1970s we didn't see
and emma there's a dimension in that
question for you i'm interested in the
the retail view on this because um
lee says the bank of england seemed to
think that consumer spending is driving
inflation are we seeing that in the
shops and you know once people access
their savings and burn through them will
it all slow down
i think as people have
less disposable income obviously that
will impact um what they spend on
non-essentials but i think paul is
exactly right the the bank of england
and the government have very few levers
that they can pull because of the
diverse range of factors um many of
which are indeed global that are feeding
into inflation whether that's higher
energy costs transport costs labour
costs or global commodity prices there's
very little the bank of england can do
about most of those things
okay well thank you all very much indeed
out of time emma revel paul johnson
catherine chapman very good talking to
you thank you very much indeed got time
for a very quick look at the weather i
think
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
so it's getting warmer and warmer but
some rain or showers around at times
this evening it's mostly fine but
northeast scotland will stay rather dull
and damp mist and low cloud will affect
some northern and southwestern coasts
it'll be mainly dry overnight